-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy Award-Winning director,
writer, and actor you know
from his work
on the fantastic limited series
"Escape at Dannemora"
and films such as "Zoolander"
and "Meet the Parents."
He both executive-produced
and directed "Severance."
You can catch new episodes
on Apple TV+ every Friday,
with the season finale
available on April 8th.
Please welcome back to the show
our friend Ben Stiller,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome back!
I'm so happy you're here.
-I'm so happy to be.
I feel like I'm in the show.
I'm a fan of the show.
So when you're on something
that you're a fan of,
it's kind of, I feel like
I'm in the television.
-Oh, well, that's --
I'm glad we can
make that very eerie thing
happen for you.
-I love --
I've told you this before,
but I love the show
and I love what you do
at "A Closer Look."
It's exciting to see
"A Closer Look" live.
-[ Laughing ]
Thank you very much.
-Or a distant look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
-And I just think --
And you're one of our
unsung great impressionists.
-Thank you very much.
-Right?
isn't he one of
the best impressionists?
-I'm blooming late
as an impressionist.
-But they're really good
and really specific.
The Pacino -- Just now,
the Pacino, De Niro.
-I don't want to be --
I'd love to be humble,
but I'm really good at them.
-Yeah, no,
you are really good.
[ Laughter ]
You're like Byner level.
-[ Laughs ]
That's so kind.
Hey, so, you -- Obviously,
you grew up in show business.
-Yes.
-Your parents were
two fantastic comedians,
Jerry Stiller and Anne Meara.
Grew up in New York,
spent a lot of time in L.A.
-Mm-hmm.
-And obviously,
you fell in love
through your parents,
but also as a viewer
of movies and television.
Do you remember, like, early,
going to the movies,
early on in your life?
-I've always loved movies.
You know, grew up in the '70s,
so it was
a great era for movies.
And, yeah, my parents were
always working in Los Angeles
a lot.
We lived in New York,
so my sister and I
would go out with them sometimes
in the summer
when they would work.
And one time, they were staying
at the Sunset Marquis in L.A.,
which is this sort of
like cool, hip hotel.
It was probably like 1974.
And they went off
to do a game show.
Might have been
"Hollywood Squares"
or "Tattletales"
or something like that.
And my sister and I got the girl
who was babysitting us,
this 16-year-old -- apparently,
she was an actress, too.
I don't remember.
But she took us
to see "The Exorcist."
-Okay. How old are you?
-I am nine.
[ Laughter ]
I was really excited
because my parents
didn't know we went.
We took a cab down to, I think
was, like, the Chinese Theatre
or something.
And we went in,
and we saw one of the most
horrifying movies ever made,
that had an incredibly --
I mean, literally,
I was so affected by it,
I couldn't speak.
We went back to the hotel.
My parents came back from work,
and I was like this.
[ Laughter ]
Insisted on sleeping with them
in the bed for the whole week.
And of course, we never
told them what happened.
-Oh, God!
-Yeah.
-They probably thought something
far worse happened to you.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, right, yeah.
And I mean, it was Hollywood.
[ Laughter ]
But it was an amazing movie.
But, yeah, I'll always
remember that.
-Probably a little too early.
It's so funny,
as having kids now,
that realizing that threshold of
when it's the right time
to show a movie,
because in your head,
you remember you were fine
when you saw it,
but they really can
do a number on you.
-Yes, for sure.
And also the movies back then
that were acceptable for kids
to see at that age,
even though we were probably
a little young
for "Exorcist," but, you know,
all the action movies,
even, you know, people are
getting killed all the time.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
-It's just like
a whole different world.
People smoking cigarettes,
killing people.
-Yeah, yeah, it's true.
You start these movies
and you're like,
"Now, this is the good guy.
Everything he does, you're
not allowed to ever do."
-Right, right.
-I know this about you
because, obviously, we know you
as an actor and a comedian.
It's been so exciting,
both with this show
and "Dannemora,"
you did want
to be a director first,
more than anything.
-Yeah, I always wanted
to be a director
since I was like
probably 9 or 10 years old,
and my parents were always,
you know, actors.
but I always thought,
"Oh, I want to direct."
And I would, you know,
get all the magazines
like, you know,
"American Cinematographer."
And I was fascinated
with the behind the scenes,
and I was making Super 8 movies
as a kid.
-So, you have a Super 8 camera,
and then what kind of
movies are you making?
-I was making little
murder movies in Riverside Park.
-Yeah, okay.
-Yeah, it was, you know, like,
it was the time that
"Death Wish" was, you know --
-Yeah, and probably
that era of New York,
you might actually
catch a murder
if you were out there
just shooting.
-Possibly.
The Zapruder film image.
-Who were your cast
in those early movies?
-It was usually friends.
Or once I did
"The Tell-Tale Heart."
You know that story?
-The Poe?
-The Edgar Allan Poe story.
It's about a man who lives --
It's a weird story.
It's a guy who lives with a man,
just he lives with him,
and the man has an evil eye.
The guy believes
he has an evil eye.
So every night, he sleeps
with his eye open,
and the guy goes in
to check on him,
and he's convinced the evil eye
is staring at him.
So he decides
he has to kill the guy.
That's the story.
-Yeah.
-So, we made the movie,
and I cast my dad
as the man with the evil eye.
-Uh-huh.
[ Laughter ]
-And we shot
at my friend's house,
and my dad was awesome.
He totally supported
all the moviemaking.
And you know, he got, like,
an old-timey kind of,
you know, nightgown
that we rented.
And then he was in the bed and
he'd, like, hold his eye open
and we'd zoom in on his eye.
And then my friend
had to chop him up.
And so we put him
in the bathtub,
and he put his, you know,
his leg over the bathtub edge,
and we pretended we were
chopping his leg off.
[ Laughter ]
-I don't know, I feel
like you were maybe
too old for "The Exorcist"
when you saw it.
[ Laughter ]
-It might have affected
that movie, yeah.
I also did "King Kong."
That was before, like, remember
the Jeff Bridges "King Kong"?
-Yes, of course.
-Yeah, I got obsessed with that,
and I decided I was gonna
build the King Kong hand.
That's how they did
the special effects,
where she would get in the hand
and they'd have
a rear projection.
And so I got as far
as getting the lumber
and getting, like,
a piece of plywood
and 2x4s and hinges.
And I made the hand.
-Really?
-Just, like, the armature.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And then I sort of
ran out of gas.
[ Laughter ]
And it just was in my room
for like two years,
this weird wooden hand.
[ Laughter ]
-So, I think I recognized you
years ago,
'cause I saw this movie,
not when it came out,
but years later.
You were in a Spielberg film
as a young man, as an actor?
-Mm-hmm, "Empire of the Sun."
It was one of
the first jobs I had,
and we played prisoners of war.
It was Christian Bale's
first movie,
and it's based on
a J.G. Ballard novel.
So we were in
a prisoner-of-war camp
that was supposed to be
in China,
but we shot in Spain,
and I was just, like,
almost an extra.
I had like two lines.
And it was really exciting
'cause I was
a huge Spielberg fan.
And he'd come to see
a play I was in,
and he basically cast me
in the movie.
He said, "Hey, you know, I think
you'd be great for this part.
Do you think
you could lose some weight,
because you're supposed
to be in a prison camp?"
So I showed up at the set.
I had lost about 28 pounds.
And he looked at me
and he said, "Are you okay?"
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "You told me
to lose weight.
You're Steven Spielberg."
[ Laughter ]
But I did, one time,
I had an awful moment
where there was, like,
a really long Steadicam shot,
you know, where the camera
is just, like,
following Christian bale out.
He's, like, coming out
from the reeds.
He was, like, hunting a quail
or a pheasant or something.
And he comes back in
through the barracks
and finally gets to us.
I'm next to John Malkovich.
I have one line
in the whole movie,
and the camera gets to me.
it's after like three or four
minutes of this shot.
And I say my line.
I'm supposed to say, "Hey, kid,
would you like a Hershey bar?"
And I screwed it up, and I said,
"Hey, kid, would you like
a chocolate bar?"
And then I went, "Oh, damn,
I'm sorry, cut."
And there's silence.
And then I just hear, from out
where the monitors are, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
I was like, "I'm sorry.
I screwed up my line."
And then I hear Steven Spielberg
say, "You never yell 'cut'!"
[ Laughter ]
And of course, my hero, my idol.
I'm realizing I just did the
most embarrassing thing ever.
So it worked out fine.
-Yeah, it worked out.
I guess it really
speaks to the fact
that "director first,"
if you're willing to yell "cut"
on the set.
-I couldn't help myself.
-He probably took you aside
and he's like,
"You should get into directing."
-Exactly.
-I have so many questions
about "Severance."
We'll be right back
with more from Ben Stiller.